andrew's with us in san antonio texas
hey andrew what's up
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve man how can i help
awesome i had a question um so i'm like
you just said living in san antonio uh
i'm in the military right now
um we got about probably three years
left about and
i actually called i spoke to ken coleman
a couple weeks ago and he encouraged me
that
uh this is probably should probably look
at me my last enlistment because it just
doesn't line up with my goals anymore so
we're kind of looking at that transition
and we're plotting
a move to the nashville area actually at
the end of this english net
you and the rest of america okay
um so the house that we're living in now
is very much a starter home we bought it
when we moved here um
for about 170. um and we're just
wondering like at what point is it
appropriate mathematically to move up in
house because the house we live in like
we'd like to be in a nicer part of town
eventually you know a little bit bigger
and so we're just trying to figure out
like mathematically how to make that
happen without like starting over on the
mortgage you know
okay well you uh number one you wouldn't
do this until you move
to nashville i mean three years out you
ride that house for three years
it doesn't make sense to buy and sell a
house inside of three years
right no we're not looking at doing this
now i'm just just for planning purposes
yeah so you sell the house there
you move to nashville start your new
career buy another house right
right and then you would start a new
mortgage on a 15-year
fixed rate here's the thing when someone
says starting over on the mortgage
that makes me think that you believe
that
all the interest on a mortgage is paid
up front
which is not true by the way do you
think that
no i don't think that okay good i guess
so what's your strong all you're
starting over is you have a different
debt a bigger debt or a smaller debt
so what do you currently owe on san
antonio house
currently we owe 155 okay so if you buy
155
at the same interest rate or less in
nashville which would be very hard to do
or the nashville market you could get
out in the country you might way out in
the country you might pull that off okay
but
anyway uh if you did that mathematically
speaking
you would exactly start where you are
today
you would just move the 155 at the same
interest rate over here
and if it was the same number of years
you would have lost zero ground
the only way you lose ground is you go
further in debt which you said i want to
move up in house that's cool
so let's say you buy a 300 000 house
because your career your new career pays
more than your old career
and you move to nashville by 300 000
house now that's a little more feasible
okay uh and so now you've doubled your
mortgage
so what you've started over is twice as
much debt
but nothing else started over other than
that
okay yeah that makes sense how many
years remaining on your current mortgage
uh we've only lived in this house for
just less than a year so we've got 14
years left oh so you did a 15 year
okay so when you move you would have 11
years left if you did my scenario
on 11 years regardless of the amount you
took out
you would still be debt-free at exactly
the same time agreed
okay yeah that sounds yeah yeah which
you wouldn't do that you'll probably get
a new
15-year 300 325 000 or whatever number
it is when you move up
that's all fine as long as it's on a
15-year fixed where the payments no more
than a fourth of your take-home
pay but that's how it's going to work so
sit tight where you are and then as you
arrange yourself into the new career
three years from now and you decide
which city you're going to live in for
sure you start shopping for real estate
and start figuring out how much we
actually can afford
based on your new income to purchase on
a 15-year
fixed rate where the payment's no more
than a fourth year take-home pay
and that'll keep you between the ditches
brother hey thank you for your service
we really really appreciate you guys